as we enter the final weeks of summer
inflation lingers supply chain delays
continue and interest rates are up while
an official recession has not been
declared these factors can make one feel
imminent there are a number of other
signals that while unusual are also
warnings a recession could be on the way
google search trends
between july 24th and 30th the same week
it was reported that u.s gdp shrank for
a second consecutive quarter online
searches for recession exploded
according to google trends the term was
searched more in that week of july than
any other week since 2004. lemon.io a
marketplace of vetted software
developers analyzed google search trends
and also found searches for will i lose
my job in a recession are up nine
thousand nine hundred percent searches
for what to do when you get laid off are
up three hundred and thirty six percent
and searches for lost my job can't pay
rent have risen 467
mlb attendance
attendance at games through the first
half of the 2022 season was down at 23
of 30 ballparks compared to 2019 game
attendance overall has been on a
downward trend even before the pandemic
but luxury and recreational purchases
like game tickets are typically some of
the first items consumers cut down on
when the economy cools down according to
simasha
chief strategist at principal global
investors but shaw also warns a problem
with this data at the moment is it's
hard to separate what is a post-pandemic
fear of large crowds from economic
trends
private label sales consumers of all
income levels are increasingly swapping
out name brand products for less
expensive generic substitutes analytics
firm in market reported 46 of
respondents to a survey in june said
they're turning more to store brand
products than before this also includes
gen z buyers whose spending on private
labels grew nearly 36 between february
and march this year and finally believe
it or not
men's underwear can also be an indicator
back in 2008 former federal reserve
chairman alan greenspan told npr that
men's underwear sales is one way to tell
how an economy is doing as it is
typically one of the last items of
clothing people look to buy if there's a
dip in sales this could mean wallets are
stretched thin as household budgets are
more focused on food and gas
[Music]
you